[Music]
if I'm hard on you just because the
world is hard
you've seen that
and I just need you stay out of trouble
okay oh my god
your brother just got out of prison I
know I've been away for a long time but
I want to make sure that you know that
you're important to me I want you to be
careful around him welcome home my man I
know I owe you guys some money I just
wanted you can all I'm not dodging you
oh let him go the hell is that thing
what the hell is that I found it
somebody's got to be looking for this
thing
that thing your brother hasn't there you
need to constantly attentive it
[Music]
finally exist somewhere dangerous people
coming after us
I know I'm not a good guy but it's been
pretty incredible to be brothers for the
first time whatever it has gotten him
into
he's gonna figure it out eventually I
hope you're ready for that can't believe
this whole time
you haven't told me there
get away from my brother maybe keep that
thing on the first mode yeah
[Music]